Drew Barrymore's not my girlfriend in
this scene that's probably a good thing
because I would have been gutted by the
end of it the events of this movie
happened 20 years ago
but even then stovetop popcorn was very
much a thing of the past Halloween no
the one with the guy in the white mask
who walks around in stocks babysitters
nope never heard of it thanks for the
plot synopsis hey since we're being self
referential how about firestarter even
Wes Craven's new nightmare hello Wes are
you no let you get away with this yeah
let's turn those outside lights off this
is the right time to conserve and go
green does she know about answering
machines not answering the phone is very
much an option Jesus every door
in this house was unlocked how many
doors does someone need to go in and out
of in one house while you're alone
without ever logging them back and two
seconds away from calling the police
so therefore don't even bother because
the killer on the other end of the line
said so landshark killer wasn't
threatened by the police but he will
definitely be frightened of the imminent
arrival of her high school-aged
boyfriend how did the killer's get Steve
taped up to this chair since the last
time KC looked outside remember one of
them is talking to KC
and the other one is probably Matthew
Lillard so setting this up would not be
easy you didn't how could you be so
well-versed on the first Friday the 13th
and not know mrs. Voorhees was the damn
killer realize that absolutely no one is
visible in these shots who could be
cutting out Steve's intestines right now
unless there was some sort of elaborate
Rube Goldberg device knocking over a
final Domino girl who literally just
found out her boyfriend was dead by
seeing him 20 feet away gutted like a
fish sets please leave me alone to the
killer on the phone instead of just to
last time she ran around locking doors
that kind of at least five there's no
way even in a two killer system that the
woman costume could have known case he
was here for a perfectly time scare
unless he's got a radio in his
hood now he's throwing his entire body
through the window like it's no big deal
BIRT air and his cheaply made party city
Halloween costume instead of continuing
to run in this cars direction she stops
giving the killer time to do that
thankfully for the sake of the parents
most horrific evening ever Casey those
stabbed multiple times still somehow
holds onto the cordless phone while
being dragged away again these two have
to be virtually Supernatural killers to
hang Casey like this and the amount of
time that they had I heard screaming no
obvious teen coverup behavior is obvious
but father forgets all about it anyway
and so I won't be back til Sunday her
dad probably told her all this
information before this book but repeats
it now so Billy who is definitely the
killer would know that she would be home
alone exorcism especially the crucifix
scene so sexy discount Johnny Depp from
cry-baby hair staff they're
interrogating the entire school maybe
that you just looked for the person that
has a busted lip broken nose sore crotch
and a cut a pan from punching through a
window the police just want to ask you a
few questions
creepy principal touches his students in
a weird way in front of the cops patty
that's an amazing Kristen Stewart
impression considering Kristen Stewart
was only six years old when this film
was made in are the police aware that
you dated the victim apparently not even
after asking the whole damn school
questions today still wasn't me
yeah uh what considering what we find
out later do have a twin that was with
her last night
does she not know the time of death what
the are you saying Billie did all
that himself authorities are baffled by
the lack of clues not even phone records
later we find out they clone a cell
phone to frame Sidney's death but whose
phone did they clone this time
Steve's otherwise wouldn't Sydney's dad
or whoever cell phone they cloned be a
suspect right now girl whose mom was
killed a year ago and who is home alone
now and who knows two teens were
murdered last night chooses to walk
toward the front porch after hearing
this you do after two of your classmates
were murdered after you yourself have
been on edge because of how similar it
is to your own mom's killing billions do
actually want to kill Sidney right now
according to the grand scheme they admit
to her later they try and pin it on her
dad who went crazy on the one-year
anniversary of her mom's death but today
is not that anniversary and they have a
lot more people to kill before the grand
finale so was this the plan or did they
add victims on the fly why aren't you
killing her oh I see you were waiting
for the kick she needed extra time to
muster got it if your phone is dead and
how does your internet work in 1996 it
was pretty much all dial-up Billy's
showing up during the attack should set
off all your alarm bells except the
movie goes so far out of its way to
belittle typical horror cliche is that
you in no way suspect him even after he
drops this suspicious phone and everyone
in the movie start suspecting him which
is why I'm giving this movie once in all
right here only seconds after her 9-1-1
computer chat the cops show up at her
house holding the ghost face mask up to
the door only to scare whoever opens the
door list I guess it's okay you left
this costume behind as it doesn't seem
like the police will use it to find any
actual evidence like hairs but just
letting everyone touch it it but it
wherever let me ask you this what are
you doing with a cellular telephones huh
oh the 90s when someone with a cell
phone could be considered suspicious
just because they had a cell phone
what's burrow police have been looking
for the boob inspector for years but
he's right under their noses way out of
this place there sure is and guess what
perfect timing to run into Sidney who's
leading out the back way this very
minute no one is worried about the
assault Sidney just committed around a
bunch of cops
Jesus why would you even have this on in
the first place if Sidney is staying the
night
it's called tact Greg also context or
you said it's cool you'll be safe
unapologetic Sydney decides she needs to
talk to Gail after punching her for some
reason and that reason is the
expositional back story for the audience
he left his coat at your house after
your mother seduced him I saw him leave
wearing it how did the scenario unfold
Sydney's mom was banging cotton while
Sydney was at home let a killer came in
and made sure Sydney could see him
leaving with Cotton's conveniently left
behind jacket on
there's some serious details missing
from this narrative I was attacked and
nearly filleted last night that seems to
be a stretched from clumsily chased by a
dude in a costume which would have been
my interpretation of last night's events
mama left town she's not lying in a
coffin somewhere lying in a coffin
somewhere is a strange way of describing
that your mother is dead the principal
made them leave the mask on so he could
dramatically take them off fairness
would be to rip your insides out thank
you from a tree Cindy's everyone's a
suspect structure who's helped out
tremendously by the way over the top and
most inappropriate principal ever cruel
bathroom girl resumes a conversation
that was obviously in a total dead stop
for at least 10 seconds while Sydney
walked in plus she apparently didn't
even hear Sydney come in I decided to
talk at full volume for any asshole to
hear it someone there this is what you
do when an empty bathroom calls your
name of course you do not run the bloody
hell out of there immediately
was the killer just taking out the
bathroom hoping she would come in if so
he got incredibly lucky because it
didn't take her much time to use that
particular bathroom Sydney's almost been
murdered twice but instead of being
protected by the police in her own home
she decides to go to a party where
someone could easily lose track of her
whereabouts Luffy is spinning entirely
too much time on whether the Fonz did
this it's literally impossible for
anyone to have knocked on this door and
disappeared in time movie ninja magic is
the only explanation hey kids that's
what's graven playing Freddy Krueger and
if you're a kid how do you know what
that means
you have awful parents so we are now to
believe is that Billy's been hiding in
this office this whole time waiting to
kill the principal why would the killer
be going after this asshole as bad as
this guy is it's unbelievable Billy or
Stu would waste time on him before the
big finale
the killer is snooping around in costume
in broad daylight oh that's in poor
taste okay just a second ago we saw the
Ghost Face running around Sydney's
backyard now both killers are here in
the video store somehow despite someone
running around the Prescott property for
what was apparently no reason
now that Billy tried to emulate her do
you think Syd would go out with me who
the pass this question to the best
friend of the guy he was going out with
a girl you're interested in there's a
formula
a very simple formula Randy isn't fired
immediately the stores
due to the curfew and not due to the
fact that they read books on tape right
you know all the sex stuff how many guys
will put up with a girlfriend who's
sexually anorexic this kind of metaphor
is what I like to call tone-deaf and
inappropriate come on in a grocery store
how are they everywhere at once do only
where the hell you been I was keeping an
eye on Sydney told you over the killer
wait a minute no you're not how did you
miss the ghost face running around in
the grocery store Sydney's father you
made the cause with the cellular phones
been confirmed and to Casey Becker did
anyone remember to check the phone
records during that and why would sits
dad kill Casey and Steve anyway this
town is under a 9:00 p.m. curfew but not
only is a teenage rager allowed to go
all in one of the town's three cops is
actually in attendance a garage is a
great place to keep the beer cuz it's
apparently very cold and somehow at this
huge party no one is in this section of
the house at all getting free reign for
Ghostface killings these guys went full
out when it came to horror tropes didn't
they just walk you through the door and
killing Tatum would have been easier but
first you gotta have the door closed
mysteriously even though your victim
won't be alive to tell the tale based on
the way the killer is moving around I
would like to suggest that the killer is
Jim Carrey I suppose in a panic you'd
think you could fit through a door made
for a cat but I'm sending it anyway and
then this garage door apparently has no
safety features whatsoever designed to
lift with an extra load on it because
how things work and still no one near
this area who can see ghosts face and
the killer risks being seen as he goes
back into the view of the party area no
one seems to be concerned where Tatum is
also if there was only beer in the
garage how did no one discover her body
which tin the garage door I'm not gonna
check on them people constantly say
they're going to do something that makes
us think through the killer but they
definitely aren't going to do it so one
great big movie he doesn't turn to the
camera and wink I'm not sure I follow
do you want to be meg Ryan in a movie or
the movie itself neither option makes
this an appropriate statement for
foreplay hey how are those two things
even remotely related it's like you want
both extreme ends of the spectrum and
nothing in between
they're cops so they all decided to
watch Halloween but in the time we've
seen did they get this far into it
already
years later Gale weathers use this
footage to pits the Paranormal Activity
franchise it was gutted and hung from
the goalpost on the football field are
we supposed to believe that the bumbling
killer was able to remove the
principal's body from the school take it
to the football field and hang him from
the goal posts while the town is in
complete lockdown and the police are on
the look for the killer this is clearly
the best town in the world to commit
murder Gale weathers
sounds like I'm a meteorologist turns
out it did you not pick your own
reporter name did the station somehow
assign you the name Gale weathers and
you had no choice in the matter
guy and girl who like each other fall
down and roll on top of each other
cliche car the only reason they came out
here is because someone reported a
parked car in the woods but the could
have seen and reported this if it's
billion Stu what do they have to gain by
calling that in especially way ahead of
finishing all their killings who'd you
call what well obviously she means who
you called when you were in jail Doug
call my dad Sydney has a suspicion that
Billy used his one phone call to call
her as the killer while in jail to serve
as an alibi but there are many things
wrong with this first off how would he
be able to modulate his voice while in
prison second off the phone call
happened much later in the evening long
after Billy was questioned by the
sheriff with his dad present so there
was really no reason to have a phone
call at that moment third off I'm
doubting why Billy even needed to make a
phone call himself when he has Stu
helping him out that's what this movie
is trying to say because why would Billy
even need to lie about who he called if
he simply got Stu to make the killer
phone call you know and still think it
was me and do you the guy I just slept
with why would I suspect him I'm serious
here why would I a dude and still think
he might be the killer huh why what do I
have to do to prove to you that I'm not
a killer relationships where this
question needs to be asked are likely
not bound to last long-term
Sydney decides to use the non-urgent way
of communication when it comes to a
killer coming into the room although to
be fair the other killer just came in
the room a few minutes ago and she
reacted the same way thankfully this
party is taking place at home we're
bedroom doors locked from the outside
Sydney is saved by the significant
wealth of all these families in this
movie although what's so soft in a boat
that she could land on it without
breaking anything
what shot you know gotta say getting
Jamie Kennedy to say watch out Jamie and
behind you Jamie while he himself is in
a situation where he should be watching
out for a killer who's behind him is
pretty inspired we will remove a sin for
this cleverness Sydney couldn't run to
the gate that was only ten feet away why
did the killer decide not to kill Randy
with the sudden inspiration to go
outside and run towards the news van
because while this 30-second delay is
extremely clever it makes no sense for
the killer to act this way also Kenny
knows about the 30-second delay which
means the killer could be anywhere at
this point but still decides to open the
door anyway Sydney is able to crawl
through a space that is even smaller
than the one Tatum tried to crawl
through in the garage why did he go
through the crawl space Halloween is
either the shortest or the longest movie
ever depending on your perspective of
how long it's been playing in this movie
Yael apparently thinks oh this red using
substance it's normal let me just wipe
it off with my sleeve wait it's on the
outside of the car it's clear now to me
that it's blood the killer had time and
used his intermittent super strength to
put Kenny on top of the van for no
apparent reason
her mouth says no but I heard her say
Dewey I have to commend Sidney her
ventriloquism skills are on point but
this is no time to practice
Dewey survives this I guess because the
knife doesn't hit any major organs but
wouldn't it bleed out
what kind of cop car is this that you
can attack someone in the front seat
from the back don't usually have
criminal containing mesh or glass or
something killer who definitely has a
knife decides to grab this girl's throat
instead of killing her even though his
sole purpose is to kill her even though
Randy was 2 feet in front he couldn't
manage a kill shot mm-hmm corne son so
if that's corn syrup how do they manage
that sleight of hand in the bedroom
earlier
surprised Sidney well damn horror movies
had not done anything cool like having
two killers for a really long time so
for that it's worth us in all that to
cotton weary and despite numerous
attempts at Sydney's life I guess she
earned a monologue or two so that she
can be saved plan this big finale so
she'd see your genius why were you
trying to kill her a million times
before this also why would a killer
hell-bent on sydney-based revenge wait
an entire year and then go after drew
Barrymore
baby roll credits although to be fair
scream was not the original title it was
actually scary movie which they later
used for the spoof franchise so the roll
credits actually came somewhere in the
drew Barrymore sea kills you and shoots
himself in the head perfect ending
unless the detectives do forensics and
find out he was bound and gagged and the
bullet couldn't have been self-inflicted
because of the angle that came in and
the fingerprints on the stuff you're
framing him with but you're probably
right
who does forensics anymore no you didn't
you didn't even have a gun
until Sidney took it off Dewey so you
did not plan for the shooting in the
head part unless there's a second gun
which there is not billions to stab
themselves to make it look like they got
attacked but shouldn't this take place
after they kill Sidney and her dad
didn't Sidney call the cops from do his
police car a minute ago did the police
station just ignore the call about
people dying and ignore that Sidney gave
a full address where it was all going
down yet Gale weathers somehow stole
this gun and decided not to show she had
it until it was dramatic enough to do so
luckily for Sidney and her creepy dad
Gale somehow survives running her van
off the road and hitting a tree head-on
going 40 miles an hour with only minor
scratches she was dead how did still
have time to check the van which crashed
all the way down here then communicate
that to his partner with all they've
been doing is dun dun still has its
safety on cliche this is Gale weathers
signing off why didn't you just stab her
and doesn't that mess up your plan a bit
isn't the dad supposed to use that gun
to kill himself why would he stab
everybody but shoot Gale why yeah you
expected Sidney to just stand there this
whole time while your backs were turned
she must be hiding under the sofa
cushions check there and for reasons
unknown Sidney decides to put on the
Ghost Face costume to kill Billy Gale ex
machina also how the hell did she get
the gun yeah Billy dropped it when
Sidney stabbed him with the umbrella and
Sidney kicked it away from him but she
never ran in here to get it this is the
moment when the supposedly dead killer
comes back to life for one last scare
yeah but he's Billy supernatural like
those other killers were so is the Sun
just now coming up did he take the cops
five hours to get to this house why are
they just now taking Dooley away it was
probably a lot of traffic because those
crazy drunk driving teenagers that were
driving to the high school to see the
dead principal I'll crash their cars and
died which just goes to show you alcohol
is the real killer the more you know
Feuer in your office right now we'd be
having this conversation face-to-face
looking at cleavage is like looking at
the Sun you don't stare at it it's too
risky
you get a sense of it then you look away
cotton murdered my mother bold strategy
cotton let's see if it pays off for oh
my god they killed Kenny yeah